* Wehmütiger, afrikanischer Gesang *
.
Ein Land, zwei Männer,
drei Wochen lang unterwegs.
* Wehmütiger, afrikanischer Gesang *
Es ist wieder mal an der Zeit,
dass Jonny und ich neben der Tour
Zeit zusammen verbringen.
Manu und Jonny von DivertiMento
reisen durch Südafrika.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig
für unsere Freundschaft,
die manchmal
unter dem Alltagsdruck leidet.
Es ist eine Riesenchance,
drei Wochen
zusammen unterwegs zu sein.
Vor ihnen liegen 3'000 km.
Das wird sich wahnsinnig positiv
auf unsere Freundschaft auswirken.
Es ist eine wichtige Reise
für die beiden.
Das Gefälle zwischen seinem
und meinem Leben ist relativ gross.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Unsere Ansichten
sind sehr oft nicht kongruent,
sondern eher gegenteilig. Das ist
oft eine grosse Herausforderung.
Wir sind jetzt 20 Jahre
zusammen unterwegs -
das sind Ehe-ähnliche Zustände.
Vielleicht haben wir uns
in drei Wochen so zerstritten,
dass wir nie mehr
miteinander arbeiten wollen.
Ich hoffe es nicht.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ich weine gerade etwas.
Habe Tränen in den Augen, verdammt.
In diese Stadt zu fahren,
in der ich so viel erlebt habe -
es ist so schön,
wieder hier zu sein.
Zum zehnten Mal
weine ich beim Reinfahren - krass.
Kapstadt ist für Jonny
mittlerweile wie ein zweites Zuhause.
Es zieht ihn immer wieder
an diese Stadt am Meer.
* Afropop-Dance-Lied:
"Pata Pata" von Miriam Makeba *
Ich bin jedes Mal
wieder hin und weg.
Es flasht mich
immer wieder aufs Neue.
Wenn ich hier sitze - unfassbar.
Irgendetwas passiert mit mir -
ich weiss nicht genau, was.
Jonny und sein Mann
haben hier sogar eine Ferienwohnung.
Nein, verdammt schön.
Ah!
Ob diese Freude ansteckend ist?
Manu war nämlich
noch nie in Kapstadt.
Es ist so schön!
Ich verre... Ich verrecke fast.
Und dort ist der Lion's Head.
Ich hoffe,
ich kann mit Manu mal hoch.
Da möchte ich mit ihm hoch.
Schwenk mal!
- Langsam fahren!
* Ächzen *
Schau, das ist der Lion's Head.
Gleicht dem Matterhorn, finde ich.
Jonnys Ferienwohnung
ist gerade besetzt.
Deshalb logieren Manu und Jonny
samt Crew in diesem Ferienhaus.
Ich habe ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Aber jetzt muss ich
kein schlechtes Gewissen haben,
sondern den Kram hochtragen -
nicht lustig.
Damit das klar ist.
Jetzt wäre ich
auch gern hinter der Kamera.
Das ist die Gemeinde Egg
im Kanton Zürich.
Hier wohnt Manu Burkart mit seiner
Frau Michelle und den drei Kindern.
In einigen Stunden
fliegt auch er nach Südafrika.
Ich weiss extrem wenig
über diese Reise.
Ich weiss, dass ich dort Jonny
treffe, der vor mir angereist ist.
Ich freue mich extrem.
Ich möchte das alles
mit kindlicher Neugier
an mich heranlassen.
Ich möchte es aufsaugen,
so gut es geht.
Ich freue mich, das mit Jonny
und dem ganzen Team zu machen.
Eine coole Männertruppe,
die in dieses Land reist.
* Drollige Klänge *
Jonny möchte Manu die Stadt von
ihrer allerschönsten Seite zeigen.
Die Unterkunft
ist schon mal ein guter Anfang.
Es ist Nebensaison in Südafrika -
sonst wäre das Haus unbezahlbar.
Es ist ein Riesenprivileg,
Manu das zeigen zu dürfen.
Manu hat es
schon x-mal auf Fotos gesehen.
Dass er morgen hier ankommt
und ich ihm das zeigen darf,
finde ich voll geil.
Vor dieser Reise hat jeder für sich
eine Bucket List erstellt.
Es ist eine Liste,
auf der man abhaken kann,
was man erleben und sehen will.
Es ist mir eben etwas peinlich.
Diese Karte habe ich
in Vietnam gekauft - "Love".
Und wenn man sie aufmacht:
Da kommt ein Herz raus.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was Jonny notiert hat.
Ich habe zwei Seiten - eine Liste
für Dinge, die ich nicht kenne,
und eine Liste dessen, was ich Manu
gern in Südafrika zeigen möchte.
Jonny und ich sind beide sehr
neugierig und begeisterungsfähig.
Deshalb braucht es am Anfang
vielleicht etwas Anschub,
aber man findet es
dann doch sehr faszinierend.
So ticken wir beide.
Ich möchte Manu den Lion's Head,
den Berg da, zeigen.
Den grösste Gitarrenladen in
der Stadt aufsuchen und rumstöbern.
Townships. - Das berühmt-berüchtigte
Kap der Guten Hoffnung.
Cape of Good Hope.
- White Shark.
Ein Weingut.
- Ureinwohner treffen.
Mit einem 4x4-Offroader
durch die Baviaanskloof.
Einen echten Gospel-Gottesdienst.
In der Wüste Velo fahren.
Ich mag weder Wüsten noch Velos,
aber ich möchte das machen.
Wildlife, Safari.
- Ich möchte keine Safari.
Unbedingt -
ich kann nicht nach Afrika
und keine Elefanten und Löwen sehen.
Hoppla.
Dass jemand
drei Wochen allein verreist,
gibt es bei Familie Burkart selten.
Papa.
- Tschau.
(Frau) Ja, jetzt winken wir.
* Quengeln *
* Mehrstimmiges Weinen *
Komm winken!
Ja ... Es ist nicht schön.
Aber ich denke immer ...
Das klingt jetzt doof.
Für die Kinder ist es krass.
Alya versteht, dass ich lange
weg bin, die anderen nicht.
Ich für mich ...
Ich hatte schon etwas Mühe.
V.a., weil Alya so traurig ist -
das zerreisst einem das Herz.
Weisst ... Weisst du ...
Das Gute daran finde ich,
dass er dann nicht ...
... dass ich nur eine habe,
die immer schimpft,
nicht zwei.
Das glaube ich ihm.
Ich bin zu Hause wirklich ...
Ich war jetzt drei Monate rund
um die Uhr um meine Frau und Kinder.
* Entspannte Kontrabass-Klänge *
Ich habe heute
den ersten Frust erlebt.
Wir sind jetzt zwei Tage hier -
bei schönem Wetter haben wir
eingekauft und vorbereitet.
In 3 Std. landet Manu.
Und es pisst und ist neblig.
Es ist wie in Schottland -
und ich möchte ihm
das schöne Südafrika zeigen.
Mit Sonne, Afrika, Urwald, Meer ...
Und es pisst.
Also gut.
Wir machen das Beste draus.
Und singen ein Lied.
* Aufgestellte afrikanische Klänge *
Gut 11 Std. dauert der Flug
von Zürich bis zum untersten Zipfel
des afrikanischen Kontinents.
Schon vor drei Jahren
verreisten Manu und Jonny zusammen.
Damals wanderten sie
drei Wochen durch Schottland.
Seither haben sich die beiden
fast nur bei der Arbeit gesehen.
Deshalb ist diese Reise besonders.
Das ist saublöd ...
Ich bin wirklich nervös.
Nein, ich freue mich auch.
Ich habe schon so viele Gäste
am Flughafen abgeholt ...
Aber dass ich Manu holen kann,
ist speziell.
Jonny ist früh losgefahren,
um ja pünktlich vor Ort zu sein.
Äh ... Ich glaube, es ist blöd:
Vier Gepäckstücke sind nicht hier.
Deshalb sind wir jetzt
trotz Riesenstress zu früh.
Sie müssen etwas ausfüllen, weil
das Gepäck nicht angekommen ist.
Jetzt warten wir -
nicht zum ersten Mal hier.
Eine halbe Stunde später:
Finally, finally, finally arrived!
Dort kommt er! Endlich!
* Triumphierende Musik, Lachen *
Ihr armen Kerle.
Hello, my friend.
- Hoi!
Das war kein toller Start für euch.
Das ist erst die Hälfte des Gepäcks.
- Ich habe es gehört.
Es komme morgen.
Hoi!
- Alles ist etwas anders.
Du wartest auch schon seit Stunden.
- Ja ...
Jetzt ist für alle wichtig,
essen zu gehen, runterzufahren -
und dann zu schauen,
was wir noch machen müssen.
Rauchen, kiffen ...
Hier kriegst du alles.
Auch das Gefährt für die Reise
ist bereit.
Von Kapstadt fahren die beiden
quer durch Südafrika.
Geschlafen wird in zwei aufklappbaren
Zelten auf dem Autodach.
Damit könnte ich überfordert sein.
Ich bin froh,
schaut ihr alle auch gut zu.
Doch die ersten Tage
gehören Kapstadt.
* Lässige Afropopklänge *
Wenn bei uns Herbst ist,
haben die Südafrikaner Frühling.
Der Regen verzieht sich
zum Glück schnell wieder.
Ziehst du bitte die Schuhe aus!
Wow!
- Es ist verdammt schön.
Wow.
Das ist jetzt dein Afrika,
dein Capetown.
Wahnsinn.
Nach der langen Reise
nehmen es die Herren heute gemütlich.
Aber morgen geht's los
mit dem Abenteuer Afrika.
Und mit einer Reise
voller Überraschungen.
Die erste Überraschung
hat Manu schon hinter sich.
Er rechnete damit, in Jonnys
Ferienwohnung zu übernachten.
Es ist eigentlich absurd.
Ich habe ihn
in die Wohnung eingeladen,
die mein Mann und ich
zur Hochzeit kauften.
Über diese Wohnung
weiss ich einiges von ihm.
Aber wir haben nur Probleme damit,
nichts funktioniert.
Jedenfalls
mussten wir sie vermieten -
ich kann sie absurderweise
nur von aussen anschauen.
Er kann gar nicht
in seine Wohnung rein.
(Alle) Prost!
Im Rücken der imposante Tafelberg
und vor der Nase traumhafte Strände.
Kapstadt sei eine der schönsten
Städte der Welt, sagt man.
Es hat ungefähr
gleich viele Einwohner wie Zürich.
Die Rassentrennung gibt es
seit über 25 Jahren nicht mehr.
Trotzdem prallen an jeder Ecke
Welten aufeinander.
* Sanfte Trommelklänge *
Jonny zeigt Manu das Stadtzentrum.
Mega spannend.
Ich liebe das.
Es gibt so viel zu entdecken -
kleine Läden, Menschen ...
Hier ist es spannend zu sehen,
wie die verschiedenen Hautfarben
Seite an Seite leben -
scheinbar relativ friedlich.
Ich könnte tagelang hier sein.
Aber man sieht: Hinter uns holt
ein Bettler Essen aus dem Müll,
und daran fahren Porsches vorbei.
Das ist ...
- Das ist die Riesenschere.
Das ist Kapstadt -
damit muss man zurechtkommen.
"Was gibt mir das Recht,
hier zu sein
und mit dem guten Kurs
essen zu gehen?"
Die nebenan können das nicht.
Schwierig.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Jahr für Jahr
kommen mehr Touristen nach Kapstadt,
um Klima, Kultur und Leute
zu erleben.
Gefährlich ist die Stadt nicht -
vorausgesetzt, man weiss,
wo man hin soll und wo lieber nicht.
Das sei ein Gebiet,
in das man abends nicht sollte.
Nein. Und es ist so: Von jener
Strasse bis zu dieser ist es super.
Eine Strasse weiter
sollte man nicht gehen.
Das ist schon speziell.
Im schwarzen Gebäude
ist meine Wohnung.
Eine Besichtigung
ist leider nur von aussen möglich.
Ich parkiere hier immer mein Auto,
das ich hier gekauft habe.
Das ist mein Auto.
- Jahrgang 2010, oder?
Ja, genau. V8-Motor.
Rückfahrtkamera hast du?
- Ja, es piept beim Rausfahren.
Es piept?
- Ja, es ist toll.
Schön, schön.
Die Waterfront ist der beliebteste
Touristenort ganz Südafrikas.
Jedes Jahr kommen 30 Mio. Menschen
in den ehemaligen Arbeiterhafen,
um einzukaufen,
zu essen und zu flanieren.
Manu sucht etwas ganz Bestimmtes.
Nämlich den Gitarrenladen
auf seiner Bucket List.
Dani Ngweny
verkauft besondere Gitarren.
Sie sind aus Blechbüchsen -
so wie man sie früher
in den Townships, den Armenvierteln,
herstellte.
(Englisch)
Als Gitarrenfan zu sehen,
wie einer hier
sein kleines Imperium aufbaut
und Gitarren herstellt ...
Er ist ein sehr sympathischer Typ.
Hier könnte ich lange bleiben.
* AC/DC-Riff *
Manu ist Gitarrist in einer Band.
Harter Rocksound
ist seine ganz grosse Leidenschaft.
Ich bin begeistert.
Kommen wir zu einem Kaufabschluss?
* Lachen *
Wir würden sie gern käuflich
erwerben, du kannst übersetzen.
Okay. We want to ... äh ...
buy this.
Burki durfte eine Gitarre auswählen
und ich kaufe ihm noch eine Tasche,
damit er sie im Flugzeug
heimnehmen kann.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine schöne.
- Ja, ja.
Darf ich mir die wünschen?
- Also, komm.
You can turn it around ...
- Yes, it's beautiful.
It's beautiful.
Also ...
- We'll go for this.
Yeah!
Das trägst du jetzt drei Wochen rum.
* Fröhliche Afroklänge *
Und weiter geht's
mit dem Touristenprogramm.
Aber jetzt wird nicht mehr
geschlendert, sondern gewandert.
Und zwar auf den Lion's Head,
den zweiten imposanten Berg
neben dem Tafelberg.
Von oben hat man eine super Aussicht
auf die Stadt,
aber man kommt nur zu Fuss hoch.
Ähnlich wie Oberägeri.
Das hast du schon
in Schottland gesagt.
Nein!
- Doch.
Eine Ambi: Lion's Head, Cape Town.
* Leises Rauschen, Vogelzirpen *
* Erhabener afrikanischer Gesang *
Bis zum Gipfel
geht es 669 m steil bergauf.
Schon geil, nicht?
- Hammer.
Jonny kommt regelmässig
zum Sonnenuntergang hoch.
Dieses Erlebnis
will er heute mit Manu teilen.
Wow, so schön.
Danke, dass du mir das zeigst.
Unglaublich.
Wow.
Oh!
Es ist verdammt schön.
Jetzt traure ich drüben
kurz meiner Wohnung nach.
Die muss ich von hier
immer anschauen.
Was machst du?
- Ich traure meiner Wohnung nach.
Aha.
Das finde ich immer traurig.
Denn vom Balkon unserer Wohnung
sehen wir hier hoch.
Und jemand Fremdes wohnt drin.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich kann auf meiner Bucket List
den ersten Punkt abhaken.
Schau an.
* Kurze, perlende Melodie *
"Lion's Head mit Manu".
Sonnenuntergang auf dem Lion's Head
mit Manu.
* Angespannte Klänge *
So schön!
Jetzt einfach nicht
den Fuss verstauchen.
Gleichfalls. Crazy.
Wo ist der? Ich sehe ihn nicht.
- Etwas weiter links. Gut.
Zum Glück haben wir heute früh
den Spagat geübt.
Mir ist schon die Hose gerissen.
Man sieht dir voll in die Küche.
Die Landfrauenküche.
- Ja, voll in die Landfrauenküche.
Am nächsten Morgen: Heute wartet ein
besonderer Ausflug auf die beiden.
(Englisch)
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was er mit uns vorhat.
Es ist mein erster Besuch
in einem Township.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was mich erwartet.
Es sieht sehr organisiert
und strukturiert aus.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin gespannt.
Schöner
kann man es nicht ausdrücken:
"Wir gehen von Disneyland ins
richtige Leben." Wir sind gespannt.
Manu und Jonny
tauchen in ein trauriges Kapitel
der südafrikanischen Geschichte ein.
Während des Apartheid-Regimes
waren die Wohngebiete
strikte nach Hautfarbe getrennt.
Es gab Quartiere für Weisse
und solche für Schwarze
und sog. Coloured People.
Das Langa-Township ist
das älteste Armenviertel Kapstadts.
Hi, nice to meet you. Jonny.
- Kura.
Morning, nice to meet you.
Die weissen Machtinhaber
bauten es vor knapp 100 Jahren,
um die Schwarzen aus ihren Gebieten
zu vertreiben und herzuschicken.
Heute wohnen im Langa-Township
rund 50'000 Menschen des Volks Xhosa.
Ich möchte ein Pyjama
mit diesem Muster.
Vielleicht etwas grösser.
* Rhythmische Trommelbeats *
Schafshirn?
- You can eat the head.
Ah, no!
Daraus gebe es Voressen,
sagt Wandile.
Hey, siehst du das?
Mir wird fast übel.
Also ...
Sieht nach einem Schlachthof aus.
Hier liegen
Schafs- und Ziegenköpfe rum.
Wie es aussieht,
wird hier das Fleisch verarbeitet.
Ein sehr intensiver Geruch.
Aber ... eindrücklich.
Die Bewohner des Langa-Townships
führen seit vielen Jahren
täglich Touristen durch ihr Quartier
und zeigen ihnen, wie sie leben.
Mit diesen Führungen
verdienen die Einheimischen Geld.
Sie sind wichtig für das Township.
So steht man als Fremder plötzlich
mitten im Leben der Menschen,
die hier zu Hause sind.
This is a pub.
- Okay.
Während der Rassentrennung
durften Schwarze keine Bar führen.
Deshalb entstanden illegale Pubs.
Diese sind bis heute
Treffpunkt des Quartiers.
Das ist ein Pub.
- Ein Pub.
Es ist Tradition, dass die Barfrauen
das Bier selbst brauen.
What are we drinking now?
- We are drinking Umqombothi.
* Jonny versucht, das Wort
mit Schnalzen nachzusprechen. *
This is traditional African beer.
Umqombothi-Bier trinkt man zusammen
aus einem grossen Eimer.
Schmeckt ganz anders als unser Bier.
It's different.
The Germans love it. Be careful!
- Es ist schwer.
Die deutschen Touristen mögen es,
sagt Wandile.
For sure, they have to.
Feldschlösschen, ganz klar.
- Aber ...
Feldschlösschen.
- Sehr komisch, nicht?
Ich mag es nicht.
Nein,
aber es hat nichts mit Bier zu tun.
It's very different.
Anders sei das Bier.
Den Rest behält Manu lieber für sich.
Etwas Anderes möchte er dafür gern
mit den Menschen hier teilen:
seine Freude
an der neuen Township-Gitarre.
Wenn es um Musik geht,
führt im Langa-Quartier
kein Weg an diesem Haus vorbei.
Knock, knock.
Hello.
- Wow!
It smells really good.
- Hello.
Are you Henry?
- Nice to meet you, I'm Jonny.
Hi, how are you?
Hi, nice to meet you. I'm Jonny.
- Hi, I'm Rachel.
Hi, Rachel.
- Just relax.
Henri Jean Musi ist Musiker.
Eine solche Gitarre
sollte man hier kennen -
sie kommt schliesslich
ursprünglich aus den Townships,
hat man Manu gesagt.
Absolutely new.
* Stimmengewirr *
Wenn alle Einheimischen so lachen,
ist sie sicher nicht von hier.
Da haben wir wieder was gekauft.
Ganz ehrlich: Wir sind ja hier,
weil diese Gitarre
"genau von hier kommt".
Manu packt sie aus, und alle grölen,
weil sie noch nie eine solche
Scheissgitarre gesehen haben.
Die ist aus Übersee importiert!
A can guitar!
Have you ever seen
this kind of guitar?
* Sanfte Melodie und sanfter Gesang *
Ich finde solche Dinge spannend.
Ich war noch nie
in der Wohnung eines Fremden
und machte mit ihm Musik.
Er ist sehr süss.
Er ist kein Stargitarrist,
muss ich sagen, oder Starsänger.
Aber er hat uns wohlwollend
und liebevoll
in seinem Zuhause aufgenommen -
ich glaube, es ist sein Zuhause.
Und jetzt singt er etwas mit uns.
Musik machen ist immer schön,
auch wenn es mal schräg klingt.
Und dann
kann sich sogar Jonny überwinden -
auch wenn die letzten Rhythmikstunden
im Lehrersemi schon etwas her sind.
Is this camera on? Hello!
Jetzt kann auch Manu den ersten Punkt
seiner Bucket List abhaken.
Man sieht nichts.
Das ist vielleicht etwas verwackelt.
Sing it again!
* "The Lion Sleeps Tonight" *
# In the jungle, the mighty jungle,
the lion sleeps tonight.
# In the jungle ...
Ich hoffte,
dass wir etwas anderes ...
Drei Wochen lang -
ich dachte es vor der Abreise:
Lassen wir bitte diesen Song sein.
Das ist der, den jeder bringt.
Und ich mag gern etwas,
was nicht alle wollen.
Tag 2, und er ist hier.
Toll, der wird uns verfolgen.
Jeder mit Gitarre oder Mundharmonika
wird uns den Song andrehen.
# A-wimoweh, a-wimoweh, a-wimoweh ...
* Originalversion des Lieds
von The Tokens *
Mit diesem Lied im Ohr
verlassen die beiden Kapstadt.
Das Abenteuer Südafrika
erwartet Jonny und Manu.
Drei Wochen, 3'000 km
und ganz viele Überraschungen.
Die beiden ahnen noch nicht,
dass sie mehr als einmal
an ihre Grenzen stossen werden.
Wegen grossen Tieren
und winzigen Käfern,
auf hohen Bergen
und in tiefen Höhlen.
# ... the lion sleeps tonight.
Das Ziel dieser Reise
ist Johannesburg.
Die erste Etappe führt sie
über die Weinberge Stellenboschs
nach Hermanus am Meer.
Schon nach wenigen Kilometern
hält Jonny an.
Manu hat wilde Tiere entdeckt.
Vielleicht auch nur halbwilde.
Es ist, äh ...
Sie sind eingesperrt, merkst du?
Ja, ja, ja. Es ist ...
Richtig Afrika,
wie man sich's vorstellt.
Es ist toll, über die Autobahn
durch den Zaun hindurch
diese Tiere zu beobachten.
# Don't fear, my darling,
the lion sleeps tonight.
Willst du mich verarschen?
Ich habe das auch noch nie gesehen.
Das sind jedenfalls keine Arbeiter.
Das ist doch absurd, nicht?
Auf einem Traktor
durch eine Weide fahren.
Meinst du nicht,
das sei "South Africa in one day"?
# A-wimoweh, a-wimoweh, a-wimoweh ...
Mit dem Zelt auf dem Dach
geht's weiter Richtung Stellenbosch.
Es sind nur ca. 50 km bis dorthin.
Stellenbosch
liegt mitten in den Weinbergen
und ist das Herzstück
der Weinproduktion in Südafrika.
Ambi: Stellenbosch, Weingut.
Dieses Weingut
gehört zu den Besten im Land.
Von den Townships in Kapstadt direkt
in die noble Welt des edlen Tropfens.
Es ist ein Kulturschock
für die beiden.
Burki, mir ist es nicht wohl
mit dieser Outdoor-Jacke.
Sind wir underdressed?
Ja, das sind wir.
Krasser Schnitt.
- Ja, schau da raus!
Dreh dich mal um mit der Kamera.
Das ist verdammt geil.
* Lachen *
Erwischt! - Und du hau ab.
Die Crew hat das Gespür noch nicht.
Aber wir stehen ja noch am Anfang.
Wem von euch ist es unwohler?
- Mir!
Wobei, ich darf nicht für ihn reden.
Ich weiss, wie krass es ist.
Ich fühle mich wohl. Ja.
Nicht wegen uns,
sondern wegen ihnen hier.
Der ganze Tross,
der wie Tölpel hinterherlatscht.
* Drollige Klänge *
Hoi. Ja, natürlich.
Degustiert ihr Wein?
Hallo, Flavia.
- Hallo.
Manu und Jonny sind nicht
die einzigen Schweizer hier.
Jonny hat für Manu
eine Weindegustation organisiert.
Hello.
- Hello, good evening.
We have a reservation
for a wine tasting.
Wow.
- Uh.
Favourite table.
Das ist jetzt das schlechte
Gewissen. Das ist etwas blöd.
Vorher sassen wir in der Hütte
und tranken Bier aus dem Eimer.
Hier ist es mir peinlich,
eine solche Jacke zu tragen.
Damit muss man zurechtkommen.
Wichtig ist der Respekt
gegenüber denen, die anders sind
und nicht dieses Glück haben,
so leben zu können.
Letztlich ist es eine Respektfrage.
So this
is the same Champagne style.
It's made out of Chenin blanc
predominantly.
Chardonnay,
with just a touch of Cabernet Franc.
You can drink it in between courses
to refresh your palate.
Weisst du noch alles?
- Nein.
Ich beobachte nur gut,
wie du das machst.
Bei diesem Thema
ist Manu ein Anfänger.
Ich trinke
erst etwa seit fünf Jahren Wein.
Und auch nur Weisswein,
keinen Rotwein.
Weisswein habe ich durch Jonny
etwas kennengelernt,
weil wir uns doch ab und zu
einen Tropfen gönnen.
Nicht oft.
- Nein, und wenn, wenig.
* Aufgestellte afrikanische Musik *
Der zweite Tag in Südafrika
geht langsam zu Ende.
Manu und Jonny ziehen Bilanz.
Ich konnte mehrere Dinge
von der Bucket List streichen.
Township mit dir.
- Yeah.
Das haben wir heute erledigt.
Und auf ein Weingut,
eine Weindegustation mit dir -
ich sage dir seit 15 Jahren,
das sei so schön.
Das war sehr spannend.
Und hier riecht man
ganz deutlich Südhanghopfen.
Cut!
* Lachen *
Am nächsten Morgen. Das war für
eine Weile die letzte Nacht im Hotel.
I went into all the rooms.
* Lachen *
Thank you for that, by the way.
Das ist der Cape Dutch style
von früher.
Schön - einfach, aber sehr schön.
Und die Leute so warmherzig.
Bei jedem Satz
verrecken die vor Lachen.
Okay, you left it as a parting gift,
I see.
Ich freue mich, denn ab jetzt
kenne ich mich nicht mehr aus.
Jetzt übernehmt ihr.
Ich laufe weiter
als naiver Tourist hinterher.
Wie seit Beginn.
Bye!
Von Stellenbosch
geht's Richtung Süden, ans Meer.
Das Tagesziel
ist das Städtchen Hermanus.
So geil.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
# Ich will nach Rom,
genauso wie du.
# Komm doch mit rein!
# Und stell dich dazu.
* Ein anderer Ton mischt sich rein. *
Mein Gott, Funkspruch. Funkspruch!
Entschuldigung, nicht verstanden.
Wir haben gerade Disco.
(Funk) Wenn wir hier anhalten
können, machen wir eine Drohne.
* Griechischer Sirtaki *
* Schlager *
# Hört ihr
die Hochzeitsglocken klingen?
# I nime no e Campari Soda.
# Wit unger mir ligt z'Wulchemeer.
# Dr Ventilator summet liisli.
# Es isch aus gäb's mi nümme meh.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Nett.
Nett - es sieht sehr verlassen aus.
Ja, ich denke,
der Abend fällt uns leichter,
wenn wir Alkohol konsumieren.
Wir haben
eine windgeschützte Ecke gefunden.
Denn das Meer ist gleich dahinter,
es hat Wind.
Man kann nicht ans Meer.
Es wäre schade,
wenn man es sehen würde.
Man hört es.
- Ja.
Im Windschatten dieser Bäume
parken wir unser Auto
und klappen unsere Zelte auf.
Oh, beautiful. Thanks.
- Okay.
See you.
- Enjoy.
Jetzt ist es plötzlich mit Strand.
Erwischen wir den Sonnenuntergang?
Das wäre sehr schön,
ich würde gern noch ans Meer.
Ambi: Zeltplatz Habonim.
* Leises Vogelzwitschern *
* Leichte Musik *
Ja, so muss das sein, oder?
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Stellt ab.
Jetzt suchen wir das Meer.
Weisst du, wo es ist?
- Ich höre es nur.
Nein, Stacheldraht!
Wo ist das Tor, Manuel?
- Das suche ich.
Verdammt schön. Wow!
Es ist wirklich schön!
Im Drehbuch steht:
Manu und Jonny geniessen
den Sonnenuntergang am Meer.
Jonny, hast du was gefunden?
Ein Stacheldraht kommt nicht vor.
So, jetzt haben wir's.
Nach vorn schauen! Nach vorn!
Höre euch nicht.
Und dann langsam den rechten Arm ...
Nein, warte noch.
- Mit Gefühl! Du freust dich.
Action!
* Emotionale Klänge *
Mit etwas Romantik
kann man auch einen verpassten
Sonnenuntergang retten.
Und, cut!
Gut. Schön.
- Nehmen wir.
Kannst du ein afrikanisches Lied?
Ich versuche, mich zu erinnern.
- Nein, bitte nicht.
# (Crew) A-wimoweh,
a-wimoweh, a-wimoweh ...
Nein, bitte aufhören!
# In the jungle, the mighty jungle,
the lion sleeps tonight.
Ich hoffte,
ich höre dieses Lied nie mehr.
Aber vorhin berührte es mich doch -
das war süss.
# Ah-wii, i-i-i-i-am-am-awe.
Es ist eine trockene, ruhige Nacht,
wie es aussieht.
Jetzt oben ins Einzimmerzelt zu
steigen - du hast eins und ich eins.
Ich freue mich.
Es ist schön,
mit Manu unterwegs zu sein,
weil er Begeisterung zeigen kann.
Und äh ...
Das macht Freude.
Wenn man über eine Klippe sieht
und jemand "Wow!" sagt,
ist das schöner, daneben zu stehen,
als wenn er sagt:
"Habe ich auch schon gesehen",
"In Zürich ist das grösser."
Wobei ich schon sagen muss:
Der Mond ist in Zürich grösser.
Morgen.
So ein schönes Bild!
Ich sage dir ...
- Ausgeschlafen sehen wir nicht aus.
Der hängt zum Loch raus - schau mal!
Ich sage dir ...
Die Hitze ist das Problem.
Ich hatte gedacht, wir erfrieren.
Es war nie kalt.
Wir haben
die dicksten Schlafsäcke dabei,
die wir auch in Schottland hatten.
Wir wurden gegart.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht.
In Kapstadt waren die Nächte
eiskalt - hier ist es ganz anders.
Gestern ging ich mit Mütze,
Jogginghose, Socken,
T-Shirt und Pulli ins Zelt.
Nach 15 Min. habe ich alles
ausgezogen bis auf die Unterhose.
Es ist alles anders
als in Schottland.
Wenn man das Zelt
im Regen aufstellen müsste ...
Keine Frage.
Aber heute früh, mit den Vögeln
und dem Meer - wunderschön.
Doch Südafrika und Schottland
haben mehr gemeinsam, als man denkt.
* 80er-Song: "Africa" von Toto *
Wir haben ein Programm, in dem es
eigentlich um genau dasselbe geht.
Spannung, Abenteuer, Angst!
Entweder gehen wir Haifische
anschauen oder Pinguine.
Nächste Woche
treffen Manu und Jonny
jemanden mit noch grösserer Klappe
als sie selbst.
Viel geiler als gedacht.
Unfassbar!
Heute ist too much.
Der Traum vom Velofahren durch die
Wüste wird für Jonny zum Albtraum.
Ich bin sonst
im Moment ziemlich fit.
Das nervt mich
vor der ganzen Nation.
"Durch dick und dünn" -
heute in einer Woche geht es weiter
mit der Reise durch Südafrika.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Meret Hachen - 2019